you're sitting inside goldman sachs they
bought your business you become the head
of product at marcus it's like
do people think that they can compete
against the fintechs is it like oh man
this is an uphill battle what's like the
the mentality inside of these kind of
incumbent financial institutions at the
intersection of their core business
versus like more of a technology-enabled
uh market that seems to be you know very
very popular with uh with investors and
also users
you gotta hand it to goldman sachs you
know not having a meaningful retail
business and moving headlong into
a fintech bank startup inside goldman
sachs
was a bold move
for for goldman and it's really paid off
um
you know the the deposits
uh in terms of aum the number of
customers the apple card their
distribution deals with gm they've
really um kind of knocked the cover off
the ball and you know i being an
entrepreneur always sort of thought
about large
uh companies as these sort of slow
uh
moving uh behemoths that didn't really
innovate very much
but goldman sachs with marcus really has
done quite a good job
yeah when you think about actually uh
building that how much of it is hey we
need to go compete out outside with
these like fintech companies versus
let's think about what we uniquely can
bring to the market and just layer
technology on top of our unique
advantage like is it competing and being
forced by the external forces or is it
more something being driven by the
internal uh advantages
yeah it's a bit of both i mean one of
the reasons they acquired my business
clarity money is that we had developed a
set of technologies that
gave consumers a very useful way to
manage their money and they recognized
that that tool coupled with the
credibility of goldman sachs
layered on top of the
uh the offer that they made available to
retail uh
consumers both in terms of the interest
rate on deposits and the rate they
charged to borrow on the lending side of
the business
was was very compelling uh and that
combination turned out to be right uh
you know if you if you use the product
today uh marcus it's very slick uh it's
very intuitive uh it delivers a lot of
value independent of banking or or you
know borrowing or lending excuse me uh a
lot of personal financial management
tools that uh retail investors and
and bank customers find very useful
yeah when you're sitting there obviously
uh marcus has had incredible success uh
across the industry people look at it as
kind of the the light on uh on the hill
right in terms of how an incumbent
business can go and play in this kind of
fintech space uh at some point you
decide hey maybe i'm gonna leave uh is
it driven by like all right i've kind of
squeezed as much economics out of this
place let me go do it again and
hopefully they'll buy the next one like
what what's the general thought process
as to when you as an entrepreneur know
i should stay and i should keep building
you know inside of a place like goldman
versus like okay now i think it's time
to go leave and start another business
yeah well i'm a serial entrepreneur i
started five companies uh clarity money
which goldman bought was my last domain
money is my current business
i left goldman because i saw a real
opportunity um you know i spent three
years inside the bowels of our banking
system
messing around with the roughly hundred
ach networks that make up our
global payment system
and was shocked by how inefficient they
are i understood that in an intellectual
level but i really experienced it at an
operational level uh when i was
working on marcus and that really led me
down the path of exploring blockchains
more carefully
and you know the average ach net
transaction takes two days and costs two
bucks to settle and while to the
consumer it feels relatively
straightforward to buy your latte and
swipe your credit card and move move on
with your day
the back end of that process is
incredibly inefficient there are
blockchains anthony out there as you
know that can do the same transaction
in two seconds for a 40th of a penny and
if you look at the
the inefficiencies
in the current system and the relative
gain opportunities from the technologies
emerging out of blockchains it doesn't
take long to figure out what a big
opportunity is out there
and and the other thing that really
struck
a chord for me was just the engineering
activity if you look for a startup
focused on banking technologies you
can't find one that isn't doing stuff in
blockchains it's just there's no energy
there uh outside of the crypto ecosystem
and so the engineering community which
is really the the driving force of
innovation and where we're headed uh uh
is has voted with their feet and and
what they voted on as blockchains and so
to me that represented a very exciting
opportunity and why why i started domain
with roughly 30 of my colleagues from
goldman who joined me when i left the
firm yeah it's fascinating to kind of
think through the psychology of it uh
you obviously saw the problems do you do
a bunch of market research or like walk
me through as a serial entrepreneur like
how do you go about evaluating okay i've
got 20 good ideas but are they actually
great ideas is it worth starting a
company what's the actual addressable
market like what does that process look
like for you yeah i like that question
because i have a good answer for it so
we did about 10 000
consumer uh surveys where we really got
into the head of different personas
uh around investing in crypto investing
in in this new asset class
and what's really clear is that you have
you know a very powerful uh early
adopter crowd that makes up you know in
large part you know maybe your audience
anthony but there's a much larger
segment of the population out there that
recognizes that you know crypto is is
here to stay it's a big deal they don't
really understand it they want to make
it part of their uh portfolio don't
really have a good way to do that other
than guess
and guessing is not a great investment
strategy and so we saw an opportunity to
come to market with a set of portfolios
that we've curated and managed uh
through our investment team that spends
every day thinking about which of the
blockchain technologies and
opportunities are the most interesting
from an investment standpoint and we've
come to market with you know managed
portfolios you press a button and we'll
buy a basket of assets for you and we'll
manage those assets um over time
that's a
you know a pretty compelling value
proposition from my standpoint i'm
obviously biased because i built the
business around it but to answer your
question you know i i see very clearly a
real disconnect between these
technologies and consumers experience
let me explain what i mean you know the
average consumer can touch amazon touch
disney touch tesla but it's very tough
for the average investor out there to
really get their head around what is
solana what is cardano what is the
theory what's polygon what are these
technologies and which ones are likely
to win and so i think there's a real
need in the market for a solution like
the one we offer which is we have an
investment team we stay very close to
the developer community we really watch
these protocols carefully we look at uh
transaction activity economic utility uh
relative to alternatives and we make our
bets based on those those parameters hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time